All right. You're done.
Let's look at the solution.
All right. We'll move to WeatherProvider.
We start by creating
a third selection query
up at the top of our provider,
much like the second query except that
we search for the exact date
rather than a greater than or equal date.
We then add a function
that uses the weather contract functions
to get the date
and postal code from the URI.
We use the new query we just wrote.
And the same SQLI query builder
we used before,
since it only defines the join.
And then we just call
this function in the weather
with location and date switch statement
in our query.
That's it.
Those are all the queries we
plan to use for Sunshine,
but we still need to test.
Let's go back to test provider.
As you can see, our test
has a very, very good model already.
Let's fix up some of these old tests
and close the weather cursor.
Now, we can simply copy this test over.
It turns out that the exact same data
is required for our new URI.
All we have to do
is to build weather location with date,
instead of saying weather location
with start date,
and we should get the same result.
Let's see if that's really true
by running our tests.
And our test passed.
So we've now implemented
all of the queries,
but we're not done
with our content provider yet.
After all, we're not writing any data
into the database
through our content provider.